if you're 50 years old and you're
hearing this message right now and
you're like man how could i ever do that
i started my game when i was 51 years
old
literally
it's 51 years old
i flown 3 million miles on american and
delta
and united
and continental plumo and southwest
and northwest i flew them all
did whatever i had to do most the time i
was flying coats
close the time i was flying coach in
order and hoping for an upgrade
uh sometimes i was just flying on a ward
mile
doing everything i could busting my ass
saving my money parking my doe i was
flying i don't know probably 120 000
miles a year
i barely saw elena
and elena and i got
sat down one morning we didn't have any
kids yet but my right arm started to get
tired
and uh
we said hey we got to change the game
man
i'm going to destroy my life
my health
is 51 years old buying commercial
everywhere
and literally we got on the same page
came up with a plan
here we are today
i'm so proud of you yeah thank you if
you're over 50 years old and you're
hearing this message right now and you
you're not where you want to be
maybe you're married
maybe your marriage is paying a price
right now you're busting your ass man
and you're like how do i ever get ahead
you see these people on these planes
over here thank you
see these people on these planes
you're like how do they do that
look you got to figure out one or you
committed
because a lot of you're just going to
give up you're going to be like like i
used to do that you'd be like this it's
impossible to ever have this impossible
so number one you got to be like hey it
is possible
if i can do it you can do it if they can
do it
if they can do it look it's possible so
first you got to say hey it's possible
for me if it's possible for them need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation hey it's evan carmichael and i
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
grant cardone and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy
rule number two strive to be the best
how did you get started like what was
your first company what did it look like
how did all that happen my first company
was working for somebody else you know
like until
it wasn't until i figured out how to
make somebody else rich that i could be
rich like
i hear a lot of guys saying i don't want
to work for somebody else i don't want
to keep making other people
when i became successful in another
company
and then left that company and went and
worked for another company and made them
super successful to the point to where
these companies were literally dependent
upon me
like that that's the thing that's the
muscle
and the grit
the the uh
persistence and fortitude
are like you know what i don't my ego
wasn't like i need my name on it but my
ego was strong enough to say i want to
be the best
in the company like i want to make this
company dependent upon me the first
company the first real job i had was my
sixth job
i was fired from my first five
fired from my sixth job six times but
wouldn't leave the last one i just would
not leave
so literally like
i wreck stuff i i have a
terrible driving record and i was in the
car business
and i'd wreck their cars and they'd fire
me and i said okay okay okay
and i had a bunch of other problems as
well but
and then before i would leave
i would go sell something and then they
would keep me on if selling something
was always forgiveness
so um
when i finally left that company they
went under like they could my production
was so high that one person leaving the
entire company failed
went to my next job which was speaking
consulting
using my sales
philosophies
and gifts if you will
and we would go around companies and
teach them
and
i worked for him for 20 months i was
like
the top guy in this company now the
reason i'm saying that that was a job
for me and that was a business i treated
that little my little department like
this is my company within a company
and and i wanted to make that company as
strong as possible so that when i made
when i finally went out on my own which
i was forced to go out on my own i
didn't want to go out of my own i went
out on my own just because there was
just no opportunity left
and there was no way for me to score
where i was
which i i still remember today it's
important to get good people to keep
them that like you got to give them some
other
you pawn to to swim in
and so when i started my first company
uh i guess i was 29
um that was a company where i was cold
calling on businesses around the us and
canada rule number three master income
creation three the third thing the super
successful do is they master income
creation i was asked this morning i left
my home at four o'clock in the morning i
was on a plane at five okay and a guy
asked me he's like dude why are you
still cranking so hard
[Music]
because i don't have any money
i'm always broke
i reinvest all the money every time i
get any money sitting in accounts i take
it and invest it in hard assets
illiquid assets
illiquid so that i cannot get that money
that's what keeps me motivated folks
i get money liquid money
if it's not used what
it's useless
take it and i buy a hard asset
that produces income
i'm broke i got to go hustle again rule
number four invest in valuable things i
want to share with you the uh not so
secret way that thousands tens of
thousands actually millions
of people are becoming millionaires in
america today they invest in assets that
appreciate over time
they invest in assets
in ips that they control
royalties they control
things that they know over time will
increase in value
that there's a 99 99.9
chance that they're going to increase in
value and that's what they invest in
they don't make little bets they make
big bets and they invest in things that
they know will go up in value over time
that could be a sports team
uh chances you buying a sports team are
next to none same for me
so you got to start thinking about okay
what assets can i do that with okay oh
wow i'm going to go create i'm going to
go create the next big thing
i'm going to create an app and
hundreds of millions of people are going
to download my app okay chance are you
doing that
your chances are bigger than mine
because i'm not even trying
there are assets out there today that
are in your backyard if they're in your
neighborhood you don't have to buy a
sports team you don't need to be
connected you don't have to have a you
don't have to know how to write code or
do tech
it's sitting there waiting for you right
now
and it's one of the ways that i created
the wealth that i have in my life i have
we have 11 businesses today
uh and and then we have a real estate
portfolio of 12 000 units going to 40
000 units
and uh about four billion dollars worth
of real estate now
the first the 11 businesses that i own
man they were so hard
to create them stardom manage them guide
them hire people for them advertise
market get them known
like to organize it we have hundreds and
hundreds of employees in these companies
about 700 employees across these
companies most of which are startups
they're brand new they don't have a lot
of employees
a lot of risk a lot of downside a lot of
problems a lot of headaches a lot of
people the real estate almost no
headaches
compared to the value of the portfolio
very few people work at it
it appreciates the value over long
periods of time and that's what wealthy
people do they invest in assets real
estate is one of the things they love
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five spend on the
business the first three years i was in
business i made thirty thousand dollars
a year
three years fish for you the first
the the last year i left somebody i was
making 150 160 grand a year
the first maybe 27 months that i was in
business i made less than 30 000 a year
i went backwards
but the the problem was i was not i do
what a lot of entrepreneurs do
the mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make
is number one they never look up the
definition entrepreneur an entrepreneur
means someone is who organizes a
business or businesses and invests money
takes greater than normal risk with
money in order to expand or organize
those businesses
i wasn't spending money on my business
like all i was doing was knocking on
doors it was just pure effort i wasn't
spending money like
i wouldn't spend real money until i was
uh 50 50 years old
about 10 years ago
when when a guy said bro you're not a
business and i said what he and i could
feel this
yeah i was a hustler i was a grinder
but i wasn't a business and i and i
could feel it you know
um yeah i was a consultant i could i was
making some money like in my 30s and 40s
i made you know i made a lot of money
what other people would call a lot of
money yeah but i was not a business you
know what i mean i was just what do you
mean by that well i was just hustling
just because you're hustling
everything was a transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was in
the transaction yeah and um
and this guy's like well you know you're
not a business
and i was like i know man i know don't
tell anybody i know that okay like i
knew it
and because because to me a business is
i can walk away from it it'll still
operate
i was i was a guy i was no different
than when i was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and i
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either
because once i put the two together okay
i can pound the door i can learn
e-commerce
i can be i can be a product sale i could
sell to companies like today we'll sell
we'll sell a product to a company for
80 grand on a on a three to five year
contract 80 grand a year
and i'll switch immediately and sell an
eight dollar product online or i'll give
something away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that i can meet
you know maybe 40 of them that i can do
have a partnership and a collaboration
with
in the future rule number six look for
cash flow they invest in assets of cash
flow
give me a drip
let me rip
give me a little drip
give me something every month give me
something every quarter give me
something to reward me three percent
four percent ten percent give me
something to reward me to have a 10x big
bang at the end of the appreciation of
the asset warren buffett says three
rules don't lose money two don't
remember number one don't lose money and
number three only invest in things at
cash flow you know warren buffett
he's got he's a major player in uh at
apple now and it took him forever to get
there
and the reason he finally invested in
apple was because he understood finally
understood the cash flow
of the itunes account
it was crazy that's when he made this
big move
every company he's ever invested in had
positive cash flow
and cash flow enough that they could
distribute cash flow rule number seven
find the right vehicle we got to look at
your vehicle what vehicle are you in
right now
do you have any recurring revenue
do you have any opportunities outside of
what's going on right now
what are your assets and liabilities if
you're over 50 years old you're just
trying to figure out man what am i going
to do because look time is critical now
you don't have a lot of time
you know that better than i do you got
to figure this game out okay if you're
committed number one number
we
two
to look at the vehicle you're in we've
got to look at do you have any other
additional income or recurring income or
repetitive income
passive income
opportunities there's so many that exist
in the world today if you don't
understand youtube linkedin instagram
all these things like i didn't
understand any of this when i was 51
years old i had no idea how to market
myself i had never branded myself i'd
never done video like this before i
didn't know if i did a video what i was
supposed to do the video on i did not
have a product line up i was in one tiny
uh vertical
uh i had heard somebody say once the
riches are in the niches and my niche
was so tight
i wasn't right i was wrong
because i was dependent upon
this many people
i had to serve them satisfy them kneel
down to them and kiss the ring every day
and i got tired
if you're tired of kneeling down kissing
the ring
begging
putting up with [ __ ] from customers
you're 50 years old you're over 50 years
old and you're like okay i got to get
recurring revenue
i got to get something that's
indestructible
i got to figure out how to do this
without spending a bunch of money i
can't disrupt my main flow right now you
got a job right now you can't walk away
from it i get it
but you're running out of time
okay you got what 10 years 15 years 20
years you want to start enjoying some of
the money some of the production it is
beyond my imagination i imagine you
can't even imagine flying private
it's beyond my imagination that i'll i'm
getting rid of a plane
and picking up another one
so if i can do this i'm telling you guys
you can do this every time you see a
private plane or a yacht or somebody
living the life just remember
if they can do it you can do it as long
as you're committed to if you find the
right vehicle just because you work hard
does not mean you'll get it you have to
find the right vehicle if you're in the
wrong vehicle you're in the wrong
vehicle doesn't mean you need to quit
your job right now it does mean you we
need to figure out what the right
vehicle is and because of the internet
because the access to the internet today
anybody regardless of where you live can
figure out how to do this rule number
eight think
differently 80 maybe 90
maybe 95 without being a doomsdayer
95 of the people in the united states of
america wealthiest country on the planet
are suffering
no money
no freedom no choices can't leave their
job
tied down
and they most of those 95
most of them some of them are earning
big wages 250 grand 80 grand 90 grand
maybe you're in this group 60 grand 58
000 78 000 112 000 whatever number
you're earning if you look at the
the the money left over at the end of
the year into the month or end of the
the week
there's not a lot of money left over 76
of americans are living paycheck to
paycheck 55 of americans have no money
in a savings account okay 90 of all the
wealth in this country is owned by about
less than 10 percent of all the people
in this country listen to what i just
said
you and i have been doing something
wrong
we are using information that is
outdated and no longer efficient for the
kind of economy we're in today got all
kind of disruption going on you've got
to start thinking different about saving
money investing money real estate crypto
and how you how you uh do do you go over
many many investments or do you go hard
on one
we need to look at what you have been
taught about money that may be holding
you back that may not be the thing you
need to be doing any longer i'm here in
las vegas right now you know when you
walk in these casinos
almost everybody knows how to play
blackjack
almost everybody knows how to play the
little games here they even have books
how to play the games
uh the guy gets a six
he's got a 16 and the dealer's got a six
he's like i'm not gonna hit that card
and he sits there and he gets beat all
night because he's playing by the book i
figured out
two things
i figured out oh
excuse the language
i've been doing everything wrong and
thought it was right i was doing exactly
what the book said
save your money invest in mutual funds
plan for retirement buy some life
insurance
um what was the other one work hard
oh yeah you got to work hard and you do
by the way
that's not a myth but i know a lot of
people that are working on it that end
up with nothing
like my parents my dad worked hard he
died at 52 years old
heart blew up in his chest from stress
and overwork
probably for not taking care of himself
enough because he was out there grinding
just pounding pounding every day because
he wanted to do one thing take care of
his family
probably same thing you want to do then
my mom was left to raise five kids
and
only had a little bucket of money
sitting over there in a savings account
so she's clipping coupons terrified to
spend anything scared of the if the
plumbing breaks scared if the roofer
comes over scared terrified every day to
spend one penny
because she knew she was depleting the
account that would take care of the
family
look if you're experiencing any of these
same things today don't feel bad about
yourself like you're not you're not
like oh what's wrong with me
what's wrong with you is you have the
wrong information
you got the wrong information it's not
because you're lazy it's not because
you're stupid it's because you have the
wrong data rule number nine unlearn
useless stuff
you need to unlearn some
you need to unlearn some stuff that mom
and daddy and your teacher told you your
mentor your last guy whoever you're
listening to
if what you have now hasn't got you
where you want to go what you have now
in your head might be keeping you from
where you want to go and rule number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is multiply money math and
money math and money how old are you
i'll be nine and three days
nine and three days yeah math and money
so
i'm going to give you adding
subtracting you know how to do both of
those right yes and i'm going to do
multiply oh god
okay now which of these three are the
most important i think one when it comes
to money
when it comes to money
let me show you one plus one
number two two plus one equals what
three
okay good two minus one equals
what one so we got three one two
times
three equals
one wait that's simple um two times
three yes okay so which one of these is
the most powerful when it comes to mine
i think multiplier yes why would that be
because if you have
if you know how to multiply right and
you have a dollar right yeah and you can
you're able to multiply that into two
dollars and you can multiply that two
dollars into 800 million thousands
we can get there faster right okay so
watch i'm gonna give you a little i'm
gonna give you a little drill here to
show you the power of multiplying add
add subtract
multiply okay we're going to use the
same numbers every time two plus two two
plus two two minus two two minus two one
oh wait that's zero
okay that's four
zero two plus two is four
two minus two is zero and two times two
two times two it's four let's do this
let's do this we're gonna do another
because we love tens right okay we're
gonna take the number ten because i have
it on my hat
10x
wait no now you have the number 10 on
your head okay 10 and we're going to do
10
plus
10
10 minus 10
0 and 10 times 10. 100.
so so watch 10 plus 10 is how much 10
plus 10 is 20. 20. 10 minus 10 zero 10
times 10. 100. now we're using the same
numbers but notice the multiplier the
number gets bigger a lot faster than the
other two yeah
so what'd you learn from this exercise
no we need to that if you subtracting
doesn't help yet subtract no you gotta
just gonna
okay no no subtraction no reason to
learn this in school kids i've tried
tests you know you know when people
subtract stuff what they're doing is
they're like okay i'm going to go to the
store i'm going to spend this i'm going
to budget my money they're using
subtracting
to determine how much money they can
spend if you add it's obviously going to
be less than multiplying because
multiplying you're timesing the number
so then it's obviously more because like
10
plus 2 is gonna be
12. 12. but
10 times 2. 10 times 2 is going to be 20
so multiplying half much faster
you're amazing okay so when it comes to
money you want to add subtract or
multiply you want to multiply mainly and
then use the other two for pesky things
like this like stuff that's not needed
you're awesome buddy okay so now what i
have to do is i got to figure out how to
go multiply my friends and my money so i
can get beyonce to come to the tennis
book yes
friends
can multiply friends
so rather than adding one friend you
could add 10. multiply i'm just going to
write it down multiply my friends
multiply my money
good multiply my influence
united spell influence no i'm just going
to write i n i n
and help more people
because if i can maybe maybe i can help
beyonce or dolly parton or
who else
adriana earlier
ariana sorry just remember her by the
ponytail okay maybe riney heine can get
ariana
you like ryan
okay all right so okay if i can't get
beyonce and i can't get a deal and i
can't get
i think jimmy fallon will do it i can't
get ariana ariana ariana okay and i
can't get who else did you want jolly
barton and jimmy jimmy fallon jimmy
fallon who else who goes
i already had kevin i know i want kevin
again you want kevin again you love
kevin huh kevin's cool
um who else
i'm sorry kevin okay who else you want
um what about the rock
yes the rock okay what about jimmy
fallon can bring ariana grande okay um
i either want beyonce or adele okay one
of the other not both of them together i
mean yeah you can choose i mean i'll be
perfectly happy with all of them but
okay um and then ariana wait i already
said alright yeah and then dolly parton
dolly parton and i'll be happy okay i'll
tell you what i'm going to invite one of
those people or more
okay
but i need something huh
and kevin hart you want kevin hart again
i really had shorty
but look now we're both friends
oh zach you want zac efron okay
all right well you did your math class
so yeah i'm gonna see what i can do
again one or two of these people
10x woke me up 10x was not for for the
public 10x was for me i was trying to
figure out why am i i work hard i got
great products got a great reputation
great reviews people like me they like
my content
they like my content actually better
than they like me and that might have
been an exaggeration you know what i
mean
and and uh
but but even if they didn't like me
they're like do your content so
ridiculous it's so good like whether
it's sales closing marketing promotion
and a lot of it i wasn't even taking my
own advice
like like i was given advice and not
taking it so when the economy crashed
which was i guess almost 10 years ago
in america particularly
it was so devastating that if you had
any weakness in a business
like every weakness
was shown you know warren buffett talks
about hey what are you wearing when the
tide goes out well dude in 2008 9 and 10
when the tide went out every weakness
that i had exhibited
hard work did not did not
leave you
less vulnerable in 2010.
you could work hard and still you'd be
upside down in your house you could lose
everything your cash accounts are
garbage
stocks got wrecked everything right so
2010 was really the whisper you're not a
business son
that that that was the big
you're not a business and and that's
when i made a decision okay i'm gonna
build a business first thing i did was
flipped everything i'm not a sale i
realized i wasn't sales for i could no
longer be sales first i had to be
marketing first marketing and branding
so the 10x thing was really like hey you
got to get your people knew me in a
particular industry they didn't know me
in every industry so the first thing
that i took on was i need to get people
to know me in every industry while
i continue to knock on doors and pay my
bills if you don't pay your bills like
you're gonna die
and there's people around me that needed
to eat
so i had to keep knocking on doors spin
that plate
not get stuck in it too much and then
figure out how do i mark it in brand how
do i build a name nobody knew me 10
years ago you did not know my name
people watching didn't know my name like
people that are coming on the scene now
they're like oh my god that guy he's got
20 you know 14 million people following
and blah blah blah but you know i
started with one follower just like
everybody else and i was the follower my
second follower was my wife because i
created an account for her on youtube
and said you're going to follow me it's
the same thing on instagram twitter
facebook like
i've grinded for every one of those file
followers and delivered content to them
so that i could scale out to hopefully
rather than be independent upon one
united states of america hey how do i
get people in australia to know me how
do i get them to want me to come here
how do i get people in
london to want to know me canada
south america oh i got i got to be in
spanish if i'm going to south america
you know you can't trade in u.s dollars
in mexico you need to be in pesos come
over here they want to do the aud i'm
like i don't want any of that stuff
just kidding i'll take it all okay so
um
so you know you can't keep you got to
keep growing like facebook is growing
you they're growing all the
possibilities of things they can do with
people so if you want to be a great
business you you can't
you can't get to a place where you're
satisfied and i had done that i'd gotten
satisfied in my business externally
financially
but internally i wasn't
and it took the economy just getting
slashed that that finally like okay i
gotta change and build a real business
here human beings are trapped in as
spiritual beings they're trapped this is
what i believe i believe i believe the
spiritual being is trapped in a body
okay i believe i'm a spiritual being not
a human being the spiritual being would
have tremendous potential unbelievable
potential it would be the light on the
candle not the candle the body would be
the candle
okay and the spiritual being would be
the flame i i'm not i'm the flame
and and i want to see how hot can i burn
okay how far can i go how much light can
i bring the world how much positive
truth message can i bring this planet
how much more can i do
and i think the problem is people are
settling out
with just enough pay the bills
take care of my family get my little box
get my little house put my little
welcome mat on the front put the little
gate around the yard
we're all gonna be happy i don't want
the box
i don't want one location i don't need
the welcome mat i want to know the world
i want to travel the world i want to do
more i want to be in more places i want
to have friends in every country
i want to inspire people in every
language and i want other people to see
and they can do the same thing you know
and and maybe maybe maybe at the end of
all this
i just become everybody's uncle
that i never had if you're a business
owner you have to see the future if
you're an entrepreneur you have to look
forward to into the future what's going
to happen next
if you're driving a car it's responsible
to look ahead everybody agree
if you're skiing down a mountain you
might want to keep your attention out in
front of you if you're riding a
motorcycle
you might want to not pay attention to
right where you are but where you're
going
pay attention to the future
what dreams and goals do you have that
are more important than the money you
have invest money to hit your targets
quit telling yourselves lies about money
exchange money the only purpose of money
is to exchange money for time and
connections
the only reason you have money is to
exchange money for time
and people
you need people folks
[Music]
you need people man
you're going to grow your business with
people people that work for you and
people that you sell products to
be
so obsessed
with the idea of freedom and making a
difference that you will do anything
anything i'll go into debt i'll spend my
last dollar this is how you're going to
be successful folks i'll borrow money
from my mom i borrow from my dad i
borrow from from family members
i'll go raise money i'll go beg on a
street car i'll go sell t-shirts and
hats
failure after failure i'm obsessed so
much with my freedom that i'm willing to
talk to people even if i'm an introvert
okay i'm willing to go talk to old
people if i'm young i'm willing to go
talk to young people if i'm old i'm
willing if i'm out of work i'm willing
to go take a dumb sales job just to get
my feet back underneath me
become so obsessed
that everybody's like
what's wrong with you man
you change it you gotta change your
friends
you need to make these people your
friends
people that have time to get away people
that are working
people that are creating
surround yourself with people that are
doing things
that that are
seeking to be better
i was i was hanging around people that
were destroying themselves every day
people that were criticizing others that
were successful
that were wasting time
beautiful rock
they weren't looking for anything
except how everybody else was wrong
how they had been wronged i know because
i was doing this
spent all my time talking about
how the rich guy
that was had his kids in tennis classes
and golf classes
and they had a boat and they went skiing
how he was such a prick
and when reality oh sorry guys didn't
mean you to hear that
when in reality she didn't hear that
when in reality i should have been
looking at what did this guy do
to create
a situation
where he could pay for his kids
to learn
tennis
if they want to golf
and skiing
i was asking the wrong questions
i would tell my 20 year old self change
the questions you're asking
change the way you look at things
quit being so resentful hateful
you know quit quit get get your game
together my business is kind of
different i own a hair salon
um and i have
started a brand for myself and probably
went about it the wrong way i started it
um
doing booth rental instead of commission
and in the business i'm kind of maxed
out at making as much as i can make for
the size so i know i need to expand but
i also know that i have to be taken
serious as a woman and i feel like it's
a it's a difficult thing to do
and i don't want to do it the wrong way
this time so i don't really know how to
be taken seriously i'm petite i have
blonde hair i always have crazy
fingernails or sometimes it's purple
sometimes it's blue yeah
so i guess the question would be where
where do i go from where i'm at to get a
lot of attention i know i i think you
just got to get a lot of attention
you know everything the red the blue the
long nails the shortening anything that
gets attention like you have to get
people's attention you guys have to get
interesting
so again she doesn't like some of the
things i do i have to do that i believe
in my mind i have to do some of that to
capture attention whether that's true or
not true i don't know i don't know maybe
it's not true you know i know this if
somebody wants to have a movie and it
wants to be a great movie at the
theaters they got to get a lot of
attention and get somebody to go to the
movie you got to be willing to get
people not to like you
and what does that look like
just by promoting so much that you
irritate people like what does it mean
to get people not to like rush limbaugh
who's a pretty pretty divisive guy
uh says uh
you know the people that love him listen
to him two hours a day and the people
that hate him listen to him for four
hours
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours a day
so i'm just saying everybody wants to be
liked yeah everybody wants to be the the
popular person you guys got to be
willing to tell people your hair looks
terrible
oh i mean i do i'm i'm actually very
very good at my job i just don't know
how to um
take it take it to the next level i
guess maybe maybe i'm scared or i
haven't done it
what's your facebook
and they would right there nope the one
underneath that
see i don't have a picture of you so i'm
gonna go is that is that you yes
or is that your kids um that well
there's a picture of me and then it's my
daughter
yeah so i mean
i don't want to see your daughter right
now i want to show you right i have a
hair therapy page um i don't it's under
hair therapy yeah i see hair therapy i
see it right here
so like right okay now we got the
dogs yeah but now um oh yeah she's a
veterinarian
right
so like okay now i got hair okay that's
good before and after round like like
you guys gotta like like get clear on
what the message is right she needs a fa
you need a personal you need a business
page
right
the trick is you got to get attention
elena just wrote a book called build an
empire okay she has to get attention for
the book which means leak out data about
the book not about anything else but
that book what is it what chapter what
audio what am i listening to why am i
listening to it what do i get out of it
like constant pushing into whatever you
do with hair therapy
okay
and it see good good but but dinner date
but what do i do with the dinner date
yeah
so see like you
this is where everybody's like when's
enough enough man when do you just enjoy
yourself
i don't know i'm gonna enjoy myself when
i'm in a position to just enjoy myself
you live on an economic planet
regardless of your race regardless of
where you came from regardless of your
religion you live on a planet that has
two things on it gravity i can't fly
and i'm reminded every day of gravity
right or wrong every day day i'm
reminded i'm reminded of it so much i
don't even know that it's not normal
that i shouldn't be able to jump seven
feet
right
and number two
money
every day you were reminded this is a
financial planet okay i got a little
credit i don't have any cash on me today
none because i'm a real estate guy
real estate guys are always broke
okay but i got me a little card
i can use this to open boxes
and i can use it to buy a box
right see how many were told all credit
credit cards are bad how many been told
debt is bad how many been trained that
oh all debt is bad debt i got about 500
million worth of debt i got to tell you
i love it almost as much as my wife and
kids
i do love it man because it generates
income for me
now i'm telling you all this to tell you
look you have been miseducated if you're
having trouble with money it's because
you have the wrong data
it's not because you're stupid it's not
because you're lazy it's not because you
have a bad job okay i've had all those
excuses
you have the wrong information the first
25 years of my life i use the
information that is being disseminated
by tv and mass media
save your money say yeah if you heard
that one okay you were brought up on
that one if you were brought up poor
middle class
say yay
no no you can't say it like that say it
like you're proud yes i was poor
say yay
no no well you brought up poor middle
class
i'm gonna tell you something it's gonna
take you forever if you don't get your
enthusiasm right look if you're poor
admit it
[Music]
but damn i'm poor and then hate it
because you shouldn't be
if you're in the middle by the way if
you're middle class and you got three
meals a day you got a car out there you
can make the payments on you got a
little education that you think is worth
something and it's not
okay
and you got a good mom and a good dad
and you're brought up in a good family
good for you but dude i don't pay the
bills you ever ask yourself dude when
are you going to make it are you do you
ever suffer from this idea that you
could do more than you're doing
and no matter how much people around you
love you or
oh you're doing great patching in the
back you're doing phenomenal amazing
i've been told my whole life i was doing
amazing i remember being was 29 years
old i was the leading sales person where
i where i worked
i mean i wasn't the best sales person i
was the best person by like three or
four people
breaking records doing stuff that had
never been done everybody's telling me
how great i was and i was like but i
know i can do more
i don't know if that's suffering
suffering some kind of like
mental disease i'm kind of never
satisfied with i've heard all these
people talk about
i remember the guy said hey your
disappointments are
your disappointments in life are equal
to your expectations
suggesting that you not have
expectations
if you lower your expectations then you
won't have disappointments i got to tell
you man i i mean i can't even make sense
of that i'm like i have to have
expectations of myself i know i can do
better i know i can do more
so
if
me having big expectations of myself
and i'm going to be disappointed from
time to time that's the way it's got to
be the one other thing that i would tell
my 20 year old self look i own seven
businesses
and
i would not tell you
i would not tell the 20 year old grant
to go get six six businesses
i would tell him
learn everything you can about real
estate
everything
real estate is the business
that's allowed me to go on these
magnificent trips that i'm taking my
family on i've been in business for
myself for 30 years
okay six businesses do not
six businesses combined do not allow me
to go on these trips it is the real
estate by and of itself
it's allowed me to take my
wife and kids
employees partners friends on these
magnificent trips when you're hating on
somebody in your same space right or
they're hating on you remember this you
keep focused on creating massive massive
success
okay because
when you get up to the top of the food
chain whatever the food chain is in your
space whether it's financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters
or or maybe you're doing a real business
you're not doing it you're not an
influencer and you're not a podcaster
you're like why all these guys spending
all this time doing podcasts i got a
business to grow i got employees
maybe you're doing that
so
what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
i'm doing this for you i don't get paid
to do it
so if you're getting any value out of
this i'm telling you when you get up the
food chain and you will because you're
watching it you will get up the food
chain you will become a super successful
person but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time
to worry about these other people in
your space flowing power man
loving them send them love send them
customers send them deals but don't be
surprised
when they don't send it back
because they're not
no book
it tells you this
all these guys doing their little quotes
talking about abundancy
scarcity but watch how they act when you
get up there man watch it man it's gonna
be crazy you're gonna be like cardone
told me
while i was eating snow
the dude told me
that they were gonna hate on me i had i
had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude i want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against
okay because there's a way for you to
prevent some of this
some of these people hating on you i
said dude i don't i'm not gonna try to
prevent somebody from being stupid
that's just dumb i got enough insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure that these
haters and criticizers and little
thinkers don't bother you is don't be
them number one number two
keep following love and power baby
number three number three number three
get to the top
get to the top of the food chain
where everybody at the top knows you
and the people that wouldn't flow you on
the way up or wish they didn't do what
they did we saw a fight last night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking and showing off and bragging
and running your mouth
you can still get cracked
you got
you know huh
yeah too many days off man too many days
off you got to pay the price every day
folks otherwise you lose
period you will get beat
you're going to get beat in the
marketplace if you don't train every day
i'm wearing my cardone university
t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly if you don't train
every day do not expect your people to
be motivated to do the right thing if
you don't train every day if you don't
require training every day if it's not
mandatory every day you will not get the
cash flow
you will get just enough money
to pay the bills and by the way
everybody's got that figured out
everybody on the planet has figured out
how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree so don't be bragging about your
bicycles and your two bmws and your
country club that you paid for and the
roof over your head and you paid your
utilities and your gas and don't tell me
that all somebody else has got it worse
than you of course somebody else has got
it worse than you i hear this all the
time from people okay somebody gets
whacked they have a bad situation and
they're like but i'm grateful
well you mean you're grateful man you're
filing bankruptcy i know but i still got
my health
but you don't have your financial health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt you
should have prepared for it don't make
sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes
quit making sense of the failures i want
to talk to you about the cash flow
i'm talking about the cash flow not the
snow i'm talking about getting that
third flow
you work your wife works
yeah y'all cracking some
smack daddy money you getting some long
green
you made your first million dollars last
year that's right between the two of you
after you paid your taxes you end up
with four or five maybe 600
if you know how to play the game
but what you don't have is number three
your cash don't work you got scared once
you put away your first milli you and
the wife are like oh no what do we do
now you called your uncle not me not
uncle g you called your other uncle the
confused uncle he said pay the house off
you called your financial advisor start
investing in 401ks in the iras
and then you saw something i said about
cash
it's trash
a home is dumb equity
what are you doing folks get that third
flow
it's like a good snowstorm baby you need
that third flow when you can't work
you can't crank
you can't create
the third flow of income is the one you
buy you take your dead money cash is
trash take that dead money and get
invested hard assets
and only make a decision to invest in
those things that pay you cash flow
you invest cash you get back cash
every single
month
okay i want to tell you a story
when i grew up
my first failure
happened
in a baseball park
[Music]
i had a dream
that i would be a professional baseball
player
and i lost that dream
to drugs
you guys don't give up on your dreams
okay don't give up on your dreams i'm
not here to jack you up i'm not here to
get you excited i'm here to be an
example
i'm not your friend
i'm your uncle g
do two minutes with me every day two
minutes
i go to the gym and work out every day
six days in a week
all i ask you to do
turn on your computer
spend two minutes
with me
every day
[Music]
stop
stop the netflix
give me two minutes
give me two minutes
you give me two minutes every day
i'll change your life forever muhammad
ali said he was the greatest
i am the greatest
he said that before he got in the ring
i know a lot of you out there think
you're like i am the greatest but but
dude you ain't the greatest you're out
there like i'm living the dream you
ain't living a dream that ain't a dream
you're living so when you're hearing
this and you're like man i like what he
just said yeah because you agree with it
or you needed it because if you agreed
with it that doesn't help you grow
things that i agree with do not get me
my growth
growth is typically painful
it hurts
doesn't feel good i have to push through
it right think about the tree roots
growing they're having to push through
cement probably doesn't feel good
so are you pushing through cement are
you getting that extra segment in are
you doing this every day you know are
you pushing for the sale if you can't
push yourself how are you gonna ever
push somebody else in the completion of
an activity in the successful completion
of an activity is where ladies and
gentlemen
you will find yourself okay i don't end
up doing things that are destructive
when i'm busy doing things that are
constructive the truth is i was never a
drug addict
i just had too much free time and made
bad choices
this planet is filled with bad choices
pornography strip joints casinos if you
were filled up all day long with
activities if you were addicted to
productivity if you were junkies out on
potential
you wouldn't have time for all the other
garbage i would i wouldn't be i wouldn't
spend money on stuff i don't need when
is that money spent when do we waste
most of our money on this planet during
the holidays when we have free time
when do you spend your money when do you
go in debt on the holidays free time so
if i can just stay busy if i can use
time and create time how do i create
time i have 24 hours and i'm like i'm a
jam as much in those 24 hours as i can
and then i'll let you worry about me
burning out because that's what i'll
hear next
what about burnout when you you're going
to burn out look i'm 60 years old
the more i do the more i can do and the
younger i get the more i do the younger
i feel the more i do the younger my body
feels
i'm not going to burn out i'm not a
candle i'm not wax
hey hey hey a lot of people talking
about showing up
some people denigrating denigrating on
my showing up rule
it is ladies and gentlemen not 80
of success
regardless what anyone tells you
it is probably more like 99.9
of success
and anybody that says otherwise
is just trying to get some attention
unnecessarily because i already love all
you guys
check it out like if you don't show up
you have no chance of anything happening
and once you show up
physically show up
then you got a chance at the rest of you
showing up and you being
unbelievable superstar but if you don't
show up for the audition
the sales call the speaking gig
uh whatever it is you don't show up for
work man nothing if you don't show up
and buy that lottery ticket you can't
win it
then you got to get a little lucky then
you got to persist then you got to do
all the other things you got to do but
first she gots to show up look man i've
been labeled ocd acd compulsive
obsessive
cod bipolar you know they wanted to put
me on lithium prozac all this medication
okay i mean real real like serious drugs
i'm not talking about smoking weed on
the weekends and that
was supposedly to handle my energy
or my creativity or
uh the fact that i didn't like sitting
in a chair for 45 minutes at a time in
school listening to a history class of
something that happened 300 years ago
that had nothing to do with me when i'm
sitting there saying hey listen i just
want to learn how to make some money man
so you know it's finally when i quit
letting everybody all these average
people label me and said you know what
i'm gonna take this obsessive compulsive
this this whatever this energy is that
that has been
you know made wrong by society i'm gonna
take this energy and i'm not gonna
suppress it anymore i'm gonna use it
so for all the kids all the kids out
there teenagers that are being
mislabeled millennials millennial is a
label man introvert is a label
lazy is a label nobody's lazy nobody is
born lazy these labels are being given
to people
incorrectly and the truth is nobody's
actually lazy okay you're not born lazy
you're made lazy you're allowed to be
lazy you're encouraged to be lazy you're
surrounded by a bunch of people that are
lazy and then you become lazy people
that are being labeled ocd add adhd i
think they're geniuses it's waiting for
you there's this big gift sitting there
waiting to bubble up don't medicate it
and don't push it down give it a voice
let it be greatness and genius rather
than something bad you need to learn how
to communicate with people
okay the the the the site here says the
powerpoint says
learn to become a professional
salesperson
when i know when i think of the
professional salesperson
i think about a professional
communicator
someone who knows how to make contact
someone who knows how to control a
conversation i don't think about a
swindler i don't think about a tricky
dude i don't think about a huckster i
don't think about a scam artist i think
about
dude this guy showed me something i
didn't know you know how many things
that i almost bought were the wrong
thing but a professional salesperson
with a full pipeline said no no you
don't want that
one of the best sales people i know okay
guy named robert i'm not going to give
his last name because i don't have
permission i'm sure he wouldn't mind 25
billion worth of real estate hey robert
is this a good deal
yeah you know but that's not the one i
would do i would buy this one over here
if i were you okay
see
he's a professional he's a communicator
he'll tell me what i'm doing wrong he'll
tell me when i'm right tell me when i'm
wrong he'll challenge me he's not
playing games trying to like
match tones i saw this video the other
day matching people's songs did you see
it okay get get
right at the right moment
at the right moment
lower your voice and i don't want to do
that i'm talking about a professional
salesperson that doesn't have to rely on
tricks because their pipeline's so big
there's seven billion people on the
planet that are qualified and interested
in buying your product you do not need
to trick people and that's why so many
people think commission i don't want to
be a salesperson equals i don't want to
be a huckster well you don't have to be
if you're a professional my mother was
there for me when i didn't need her to
be there for me okay okay she didn't she
never let me down but but that doesn't
mean she pushed me up
you understand the difference
my mom was a great mother she was always
there for me it didn't mean she pushed
me up to the next level though because
every time i went to my mom and said mom
let me tell you what i'm doing she would
be like that's awesome
but just son remember i love you just
the way you are
how many of you have a parent that will
tell you that just remember
i was 50 years old and she would still
tell me that
she's 70 she was 78 at the time she's
like
just remember
[Music]
i love you just the way you are
you've done enough when's enough enough
grant you're doing fine grant i love you
just the way you are love yourself the
way you are man i'm like but i don't
i can't lie to myself i do not love this
i don't chuck knows what i'm talking
about chuck hates himself
chuck knows he can do more
am i right chuck
and then he's trying to communicate that
to his wife or his wife to get it and
his wife is like chuck what's wrong with
you are you broken chuck you need a
therapist
okay and then he's gonna go see the
therapist like i did and the therapist
is gonna be like oh yeah you got add
you got you got the the ocd you got the
the the opd you got the ocdacdddd
[Music]
you know i said no i got the the the
the osd
i'm obsessed with success disease
i'm obsessed
and i want my damn 200 back don't tell
me i'm a dd i take an offense to that
okay i don't add i multiply
i'm trying i'm trying to figure out how
to run 70 businesses and have 70 000
employees i'm not worried
what you worried about you worried about
how many browsers i got open in my mind
the people that operate this planet the
handful the one percenters
have different information than you have
[Music]
okay they're not talking about going to
college
they're not talking about saving money
you don't hear wealthy people talking
about i need to buy a house
[Music]
warren buffett you know warren buffett
warren buffet is not i need to buy a
house
i have to have a home to live in
warren buffett bought one house his
whole life
he never talks about it
what's he buying
he's buying businesses what's he
investing his money in businesses
right he's not buying a house where
money dies
when steve jobs died
when steve jobs died where did his money
come from
one place was apple he owned some apple
stock but that was not the majority of
his wealth
majority of steve jobs wealth when he
died
was from
no itunes is apple
no
it was an investment
uh look it up uh what's the name of the
company uh everybody's gonna know the
name of the company
oh pixar pixar pixar pixar he owned he
was he was one of the founders three
founders of pixar that's where most of
his wealth was from investments so to
get to the top of the food chain you
gotta
to get to the legacy well to be able to
leave your family something which is
really what everybody wants to do you
know every once you get the bmws you
have the bmws once you have the country
club you have the country club once you
have the gucci belt you have the gucci
belt once you go on a yacht trip you go
in the yacht once you fly first class
well you've done it even when you go out
and buy your own plane you've done it at
some point you're gonna be like okay now
what now what when do i start giving
back you're not going to give back to
society until you create indestructible
wealth which is really what everybody
wants to do everybody wants to give more
and help out more and make a difference
how many of you want to change
two things if you want to change
number one you've got to change
you want you want to change a little bit
change a little bit you want to change a
lot change a lot
[Music]
to change you got to change
[Music]
and number two
you have to learn how to talk to people
you got to learn how to communicate
you have to learn how to stand on a
stage
and communicate
maybe it's not this stage
maybe it's not 35 000 people
maybe it's one person
that's a stage
your house is a stage you're going to
talk to your spouse
your business is a stage you're going to
be talking to the treasury department
selling them stop the madness
stop the madness we're not going to save
money here we're going to make money
here we're going to go get money here
you're going to have a stage with your
lawyer your lawyer's going to say don't
do it stop the madness
you're a lawyer dude i'm running a
business tell me how we can do it
i don't ask lawyers and accountants for
business advice
record the data you're an accountant
do the job you're the lawyer
let me run the business into the ground
okay we're gonna run it into the ground
we're gonna do it grant's way
not the lawyer's way
and not the accountant's way
two things you gotta do to change folks
you gotta change
and you need an audience first thing you
gotta do is decide as a business owner
do i wanna make more money see see if
this dude this dude with the camera if
he shot if his if his pockets are empty
he's walking around empty pockets
and he's got his fancy camera this is
the the problem with the artist
they starve their whole life
they starve their entire life and then
and then you wonder why they're grumpy
there's no money i'm eating at littles
all the time sooner or later
sooner or later you hit the reality he
hits the reality i got a nice camera i
love taking photos i got to shoot grant
cardone he watches lord sugar leave on
his jet
and says hey why
does he get to fly
free everywhere do whatever he wants and
i'm stuck with my camera and no money
how many believe that
sooner or later sooner or later after
days of going to work months of going to
work years of going to work sooner or
later if he works for this man he's like
i resent this man
i resent this man i resent that man
business owner i resent paul mcfadden
the business owner i resent you so i
know i won't work for you in fact what
i'm going to do is screw things up for
you
it's called disengagement
the only business people that will
survive the only entrepreneurs that will
make it in business are those people
that decide to grow their businesses
little little
will fail
not the little grocery store
okay if you try to stay small if you try
to stay small
you will fail
okay i'm telling you this from personal
experience
i tried to stay small
i tried to manage the business i tried
to be the king of the business i tried
to have no employees because employees
cost money
i'm like i'm not going to have any
employees
i'm not gonna pay the camera man i'll
just hire him when i do a gig
and the next time i'll hire another guy
and that'll keep my expenses low how
many are brought up like this keep the
expenses real low where we can manage
the expenses
the expenses are going to be so small
that that no matter how much we make
i keep it all
you have to advertise
you have to advertise in your career to
blow your brand up you cannot
not advertise and save money it costs me
probably 400
[Music]
should i even say a number this big yes
or do i lose everybody
400 million dollars we have estimated is
what it cost me because i didn't
advertise for the first 20 years of my
career but
before you spend one dollar in
advertising and and even if it was
wasted it'd be a great dollar to spend
even if you don't get a return
you should do it but before you do that
what you need to do is spend a lot of
time energy and resources on branding
i made a mistake here not spending more
money in advertising i made a bigger
mistake not spending more
time energy and resources on branding
and you are making a mistake if you do
any kind of metrics
on did it convert did it pay off
branding will not pay off
zero you will get a zero return if you
don't brand
okay you will get a zero return for
branding in the beginning
you will get you will never get a return
on advertising if you don't brand
branding is a must it is senior to
advertising you hang around guys and
cows my friends
you hang around people that are changing
will not change you
i know this whole mastermind thing we
have masterminds i believe they're great
they're awesome but
if ryan back there
hangs around me and i'm changing
that don't mean he's going to change
so look i've seen this for 30 years
you know i've gone places where the the
only reason everybody went there was
because they were
working on themselves changing improving
courses classes education elena and i
actually great story about elena and i
the only reason people went to these
places was to improve themselves okay
i gotta tell you something only about
ten percent of the people that went
there
flew
they were changing they were actually
making the changes
the other people were hanging around
people changing just because you're
around people changing doesn't mean you
are going to change you got to do the
work to change my brothers and sisters
you got to change
it you know you know ryan hangs around
me if i change my clothes that don't
mean he changes his if everybody in the
house changes their clothes takes a
shower
put some deodorant
it don't mean if ryan does not change
his clothes and take a shower and put on
his deodorant he gonna stank
dropping bombs to change you got to
change it doesn't matter how many people
you hang around that are changing if you
hang around everybody just getting rich
getting wealthy doing great creating
stuff and you're not you're not going to
change to change
you got to change i heard a man tell me
once he's like grant money won't make
you happy i'm like son
so you ain't got any money
quit giving advice on something you
failed at
right if you take your notes you want to
write this down never ever ever
ever
take advice from a quitter never ever
take advice from a quitter
particularly financial advice the first
question i asked you today was this do
you
want to make more money
then quit taking advice from people
about money that don't have any money
this used to be a goal of mine to make
one million dollars a year
that was my goal when i was 35 years old
one day i said to myself one day i said
self
little g-dog
little g-dog one day young man i wrote
this over and over and over again i
talked to myself in the mirror i'd sit
on the toilet and say one day
one day
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a million
dollars one day one day and people used
to tell me that's crazy dude
like why do you think so big this is
when people were telling me not to
they're like why do you need to do all
that why do you just be happy just be a
good person okay be happy that you live
in america be happy that you have meals
and be happy you've got good health and
all the things that the people around
you that quit on money that quit on
financial freedom that quit on
possibility that quit on their potential
all the things those people will tell
you
to try to convince you
to quit
when in reality what they're really
trying to do is make sense of why they
quit
note to self
okay last month i distributed 1.2
million dollars to other people okay
it's not money i made it's money i sent
out so it just goes to show you how
small i was thinking when i was 35 years
old this is at the beverly hills hotel
today
if you've never stayed here you have to
okay every single day that i have been
here i have met someone
that will help me in my career
they don't tell you this in school they
don't teach you this your parents didn't
teach you this you have to go where the
money is
money is not just okay i'm gonna buy a
lamborghini and i'm gonna buy a big
house and i'm gonna buy some jewelry and
i'm gonna get some nice sunglasses i'm
gonna go buy a big watch and i'm gonna
go on vacation it's about going where
other people are that have money and
that can help you
that can help you so you can help others
so you can help your parents so you can
take care of them
so you can take care of your kids so you
can be a good example look money's not
going to make you happy you guys already
know that everybody knows that i don't
even know what we're talking about money
will not make you happy
but
it'll get you an uber
it'll get you an uber it'll get you
hotel room it'll get you access to the
polo lounge it'll get you breakfast this
morning to sit at the right place with
the right people that maybe someone
someone discovers what you're doing what
you're up to and that takes interest
every single breakfast every single
lunch that i've been here in every
single dinner that i've been sitting out
in public i have met someone that can
literally help me with my career
do you want to make your business bigger
i know this seems really simple
but the reality is if it's not simple
i don't care where you are on planet
earth
whether you're in wales
i'm going to go to glasgow tomorrow
we're gonna leave here and go into spain
i'm gonna do russia in about three
months i'm gonna go back to miami and do
business in miami no matter where in the
world i am folks if it's not simple
you're not gonna make money
listen what i'm telling you if it's not
simple you will not make money
over long periods of time it's got to be
simple for other people to understand it
the guy invests five thousand dollars
he's got five thousand dollars in the
bank another guy's got 50 grand in the
bank and another guy's got 500 000 okay
all three of these people invested money
with me this is cliff this is dave and
this is jennifer okay cliff sent me five
grand dude it was his last five grand it
was as hard for him to do this is this
guy to do that do you understand okay
this guy earns i don't know he's gonna
earn 300 bucks a year
this guy's gonna earn three thousand
dollars a year this guy's going to earn
30 000 a year
but they all had to start with this
they all start with five thousand
dollars everybody starts with five
thousand dollars including jennifer
right here she's got a five
just another zero
all of them had to make a decision
should i keep the money this is where
the opportunity comes in you got to
think in terms of opportunity costs okay
is my money better in the bank
or is my money better in an asset that
ad that can grow over time okay do i buy
a watch
okay do i buy something stupid
it is beautiful but it's stupid let's
keep it real
stupid
is as stupid does and that ladies and
gentlemen is stupid paddock
okay however
the reason the way i bought the paddock
was because the real estate that i buy
not this real estate okay i already
distributed these people the real estate
i invested in sent me a little check
check
how many heard this statement before
knowledge is power warren buffett was on
tv yesterday he's 88 years old he's
worth 83 billion dollars
okay i want to know where
[Music]
where the guy is in his cycle
everybody's got a life cycle
i'm young i'm broke
i get a little bit of money i'm middle
class now okay now i'm rich now i'm
super wealthy okay and now i'm gonna die
my data points will change everybody
agree with that
where are you getting the data from okay
if this is probably where i'm at right
now in a number of places in my life
both my finances my brand recognition uh
my international presence my business
expansion i'm probably
up on a upward slope
i might be down here and not even know
it yet
okay because i might not know how high i
could go
probably this is a mistake i didn't know
how big i could get
so
down here what am i telling you right
now get your money saved
like if you go back and read my books
when i was 30 years old 35 years old i'm
telling that save you money save all
your money save all your money why i'm
trying to put some money away
then then i get right here i'm like i
need to get the money to work
right
i get here and i'm like i need to get
the people around me making money
when i'm starting this cycle so you need
to understand when you're listening to
me today
leave here and you go to to john
maxwell's workshop
where is john in
the cycle of his life
the source of data
steve jobs steve jobs was down here
animal he was an animal him and bill
gates were like
carnivorous
they they weren't thinking about giving
money away they didn't have any money
they were in a garage
right scrapping out man buying tacos
probably stealing a little bit
warren buffett warren buffett down here
took 500 shares of ford motor company
stock for free to pitch it
to tell people i have 500 shares of
the ipo
in 1957 ford motor company went public
he got 500 shares from the company to
say he was buying ford motor company he
didn't buy a ford motor company they
gave him the shares it's against the law
okay he's outside the statue of
limitations that's what he did then
that's not what he's doing now raise
your hand if you've ever given up before
giving up and quitting are very
different things
one you never try again the other you
might
it's a possibility
if you refuse to give up i promise you
you will have a victory and when you do
you gotta get a sweet victory day
most people are getting just enough to
compare themselves to be better off
than other people if you have desire in
your heart
if you want to do better
you have to put
your money your energy where your
commitment is i don't want to talk to
you about execution and management and
business planning and
culture i want to talk to you about
money because money we believe is the
number one problem in your business
it's not mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing i have seven businesses
there's seven little companies there's
been no plan
there's been minimal organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to market okay it's one
of the things that has made us
successful but mostly
in all the businesses every business was
created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not going to be able to
call yourself a business person
[Music]
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now
so popular
i never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that i was in california
somebody said i was an entrepreneur uh
15 years ago i'm like well that's that's
code for
i don't have a job
okay today today look if you want to be
an entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money
and that provides a good living for a
lot of other people right
so number one problem in your business
is employee disengagement it is not
actually money
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see him
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way you have disengagement at a
household level would you agree
husband and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan 50 of those marriages
are going to fail okay that's what they
say they're going divorce truth is way
more than 50 fail people should not be
looking at the divorce rate they should
be looking at the failure rate they're
going to tell you
like they told me and i believed it for
a while i did but i didn't it's look
you're a drug addict you can't help it
you're powerless
it's in your genetic code and you have
no control over it
now i'm going to tell you right now that
i believe that to be complete
complete garbage
so
if i was a drug addict
and it's completely out of my control
then i would have had to use drugs today
yeah
and i didn't
so
using drugs is a choice yeah i would
tell you and i would tell everybody that
that has that addictive
nature is congratulate yourself and pat
yourself on the fact that that you have
the ability to be addicted to something
and take that addiction dude and put it
into something unbelievable yeah
because every every super successful
person that i have studied and or met it
is has the ability to be obsessed with
something
to the point of losing sleep
to the point of i don't need to need to
eat
uh i'll go in debt i'll go bankrupt i'll
go down with this make this thing happen
and that's really what turned my whole
life around was just flipping the
addiction not trying to
not be in control not trying to turn it
all over just saying hey i'm gonna take
this energy and i'm gonna dump it into
into work
you gotta advertise and you gotta spend
money on marketing and advertising if
you if people don't know you it will
cost you a fortune it cost me
400 million dollars over the last 20
years because i was not spending money
in marketing and promotion and
advertising and social media i actually
thought social media didn't work
i was so wrong about that
i started a social media company
where we actually now run ads for
companies
so that you get known the way i've
gotten known today with i don't know
million 1.4 million instagram followers
a million subscribers on youtube six
million people on facebook trust me if
you don't advertise on social media
i would call you a dumbo you know why i
have the right to because i didn't think
it worked either
all people men and women they should be
more greedy about their personal
dreams
well whatever what are these because i'm
talking about these five kids and i've
got this responsibility and yeah you do
but you also have responsibility
yourself
like how can i if i can't take care of
me how can i take care of somebody else
yeah this has always been my
battle cry like i have to take care of
me
you know and and how can i help anyone
i'm broken
i'm messed up you know i'm i'm i'm
coming out of a treatment center for
drug addiction
i didn't need to help anybody else i
needed to get i needed to get on solid
ground you know and i needed to make
sure i wasn't going back to treatment
and then i needed to clean up the mess
that i mean i needed to do this for me
because
uh
and that has been my contention now for
many years like just keep slowly taking
care of your neighborhood until you're
in another zip code they say your
network equals your net worth
your ability to move this planet to to
change things to get investors funding
money is determined by who you know if
you've got a money problem i guarantee
it's got something to do with your
network
okay if you if you're having marriage
problems i assure you with 100
certainty if you're having marriage
problems there's somebody in your
network
that believes in marriage problems if
you're having kidney problems
you know not kitty kitty no i'm talking
about if you've got problems with your
kids it's because your network is having
problems with chilling if you have a
time problem i don't have enough time i
can't find enough time i'm working too
hard i never have time i can't find time
to work out i can't find time for the
kids i can't find time for the marriage
you have a network of people that have
time problems i thought
i thought people cost money
none of these people cost anything okay
do you know that only four percent of
companies in america make a million
dollars a year
67 of all companies in america have no
employees okay so if you stay with no
employees and you're the only person
working there i promise you you will not
make money
less than four percent of all companies
in america make
a million dollars a year when i was at
mcdonald's and i got fired from
mcdonald's flipping burgers or drinking
fries or what were you doing whatever
they had me do they had me they had me
do what you know they're this is what we
do right it's a road it's a factory
and um
i was 16 years old and and um
my dad had been dead six years so
like you know look i'm uncertain i'm
15 16. i've just had sex for the first
time
everything is so complicated
making five bucks an hour that's
whatever it was no it's probably like
280. wow
yeah but that wasn't that wasn't the
problem i was grateful for the 280
but i was awkward i was not confident i
didn't know how to talk to people
um
[Music]
you know you know i hated the job
if if somebody said dude go learn this
game so you can own 50 mcdonald
restaurants
like if i would have had that
that idea i'll bet you i would own a
bunch of mcdonald's franchises today but
i went there just for the 280. yeah
not not far hey i want to do something i
think i truly think that the the thing
that i've suffered from the most in my
life as i look at kobe and
you know all these pictures of these
great people you know dude i just
thought too small i was worried about
the 80 bucks
and i was worried about what the car
dealers thought about me
that audience i was managing the bottom
half of my financial statement not the
top
one inch
today i spent 95 of my time on the top
literally inch inch and a half
and i ignore the rest
i might spend three percent of my time
on managing expenses and costs and
budgets i spend 95 of my time on the
income of the company
on how to increase the income
how to blow up the top line let's see if
they even let me in my office yeah
how to blow up the top line
in hopes
that
i can spend more money in marketing
spend more money in branding and spend
more money employees i don't think i was
built to be quiet like like they tell
you when you're growing up you know be
quiet be seen not heard or be be hurt
whatever the deal is you know don't
touch your own horn and
don't get too much attention and don't
promote yourself and
but look man god was a show-off man
look what he created
just didn't stop he's not quiet no
okay rainbows you know suns planets like
waterfalls everything yeah crazy man i
think we love people that are
grateful and have humility but we also
love to see people do great great things
yeah is there a balance that they should
have like also be grateful and humble as
opposed to kind of like the
mcgregor uh dude i love mcgregor yeah
see i like that that's your that's your
energy you like you're on that frequency
i i you know
who doesn't like it dude look at how big
the audience is yeah
you know look at the rock he doesn't
have little muscles right
but he's he's got more humility let's
say if you're coming oh he knows how he
knows how to play that game oh my god i
mean there's nobody better than a rock
at that obama was unbelievable with that
yeah it's staying connected
that's what i'm terrible at i'm
awful at i am so bad at it why
i don't know why
i don't know why i i just know i'm bad
at it i don't want to talk to you about
execution and management and business
planning and
culture i want to talk to you about
money because money we believe is the
number one problem in your business
it's not mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing
i have seven businesses there's seven
little companies there's been no plan
there's been minimal organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to market okay it's one
of the things that has made us
successful but mostly
in all the businesses every business was
created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
because you're not gonna be able to call
yourself a business person
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now
so popular
i never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that i was in california
somebody said i was an entrepreneur uh
15 years ago i'm like well that that's
that's code for
i don't have a job
okay
today today look if you want to be an
entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money
and that provides a good living for a
lot of other people right
so number one problem in your business
is employee disengagement it is not
actually money
[Music]
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see him
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way
you have disengagement at a household
level would you agree
husband and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan 50 of those marriages
are going to fail okay that's what they
say they're going to divorce truth is
way more than 50 percent fail people
should not be looking at the divorce
rate they should be looking at the
failure rate there is no shortage of
success
regardless of their culture race
religion economic background or social
group most people would agree that
success is vital to the well-being of
the individual the family unit and the
group and certainly to the future
survival of all these things
look without success your group your
company your goals and dreams and even
the entire civilization would cease to
survive and thrive
winning over and over again
and everything in which you're involved
ensures you're going to be able to
further expand and survive
and it guarantees that both you and your
ideas will survive not just get by but
survive into the future
if you quit caring then you're gonna
quit winning
and if you quit winning long enough in
this thing called success you're gonna
just plain quit
how would being successful be important
to you and how would it improve your
life look success is needed in order to
perpetuate to push forward people places
and things
you must never reduce success in your
mind or in a conversation to something
that doesn't matter
on the contrary you must treat success
as though it's vital it's important
anyone that minimizes the importance of
success to your future has probably
given up on his or her own chances of
accomplishment
and is spending now his or her life
trying to convince others you in this
case to also give up
individuals and groups must actively
accomplish their goals and targets in
order to carry on with their goals and
targets if not look they'll either cease
to exist or be consumed
and become part of something else it's
not enough just to play the game
it's vital you learn how to win at this
game
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want more top 10
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it go check it out the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
i'll see you there